KARL WEINMEISTER: Hey everyone.
Welcome to Google I/O
2021 - Ask Me Anything.
This is all about
AI and the cloud.
In today's session, we're
going to hear questions
from all of you.
And I'm joined by
some special guests
here in our Developer
Relations team.
My name is Karl Weinmeister.
I am a Developer
Advocate here at Google.
My area of specialty
is in MLOps which
is basically the application
of DevOps in machine learning.
And I'm also joined by Anu.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Hi, Karl.
Yeah, thank you.
I'm really excited to be here.
So my name's Anu Srivastava.
Also, we're all colleagues,
Developer Advocates
for Google Cloud AI.
My focus is actually
on pretrained APIs
that we have that you can use
to integrate into your app
or service.
In addition to being really
excited about everything being
in one home with
Vertex AI, I also
work on Document AI, which is AI
for all of your business forms.
Zack, do you want to go next?
ZACK AKIL: Thanks, Anu.
I'm Zack.
I'm also a Developer Advocate.
I happen to be based in
London, and I specialize
in APIs, AutoMLs,
and my subspecialty
is in everything to do with
vision and video applications.
And I'm really
excited to be here.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Awesome.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
I think you see that we have
a real nice mix of folks
from different
backgrounds today.
And we're also all good friends,
so it'll be a great session.
So let's start with the first
question about Vertex AI.
Some of you may have seen some
of the press release of course
in our keynote and are
wondering, what is Vertex AI?
And why is the release
of it important?
So Anu, what are your
thoughts on that?
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
The reason why I'm
really excited about
everything unified in one home
is that for me,
sometimes the hardest
part about learning a new
technology is getting started.
Especially if you're trying
to build an N10 system,
you need to enable APIs.
You use some authentication.
You need to maybe train
data in different places
and bring it all together.
But now it's a one-stop
shop for the whole lifecycle
that you might have with
your AI application.
KARL WEINMEISTER:
That's fantastic.
Zack, anything else
you want to add?
ZACK AKIL: Yeah,
I agree with Anu.
My background and
experience using Vertex
has been really
positive, especially
because I used to train quite
a lot of auto-ML models.
It was my go to thing
for building demos.
And one thing I really
like about the new UI
is that it centralizes
your raw data in one place.
And then after that you can
create different annotation
files.
So for me, building
image models,
I can have one raw
source of the images,
and then have one
annotation that
does image classification
and one annotation that
does object detection.
And it's structures these
in a really intuitive way.
So for me, building
vision-based AutoML models,
it's a really nice new sort of
unified UI for the structure
of annotations to the raw data.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Yeah,
that's a great point.
What I think is really
awesome about Vertex
is that it sort
of brings together
a lot of AI technologies into
one place like Zack mentioned.
This idea of creating what
are called Managed Data Sets.
So it's the same
data that you can
use if you're going to create
different types of vision
models, let's say
for classification,
object detection,
whatever you're doing.
But also, if you're
building a custom model,
so you're using TensorFlow
and writing a model
yourself with code, you
have that traceability back
to that same data set.
And Vertex brings all these
different services together.
So it's like you load your data.
You build a model.
Then the next thing is deploying
that model to an endpoint.
It's all-- kind of walks
you through a flow,
so it's really intuitive
and brings it all together
and allows you different
types of roles, whether you're
a developer or data
scientist, to be
able to use the tool easily.
So that's Vertex.
Let's go ahead and move on
to our next question here.
It is about AI solutions.
So we talked about how
Vertex brings a lot
of different services together.
Another way to
think about things
is different levels
of abstraction, right?
So if you're building
an AI solution,
the question is, what are
those different levels
of abstraction?
And I can start with this one.
So we talked about
custom models, right?
That's the ability
that you typically
think of with data
science, where
you might visualize your
data, write some code
to train the data, build
a model, take that file,
deploy it to an endpoint, and
then predict with it, right?
So that's that sort of process.
Now, AutoML has come
along and allowed
you to create custom models
with your unique data
to solve unique problems, but
without having to figure out
the best model for it.
So that's another
level of abstraction.
It kind of takes some of
those steps of the process
and does it for you.
And then you also have APIs
that allow you to not even bring
your own data, simply leverage
what Google has on the cloud.
Like, let's provide an image
and get some insights out of it.
What's in that image?
Or what are some of the--
let's put some bounding boxes
around some of the things
that we find in that image.
These are all things
that we've trained
against a large general
data set so we can apply it
to all kinds of problems.
Finally, one of
the exciting things
that Anu mentioned that she
focuses on is AI solutions.
And here's where we're building
business-oriented solutions
for things like
managing documents,
parsing forms, all
those kind of things.
We've taken the
AI brain behind it
and made it very easy to use.
So you can work at all
these different levels.
So as kind of an intro to
it, Zack, anything else
you want to add about
the different ways
you can work with
Google Cloud AI?
ZACK AKIL: Well,
yeah, you pretty much
covered it all in terms of
like, when I'm building stuff,
I sort of come at it from
a developer standpoint.
So I look at what's the
simplest and quickest
way for me to solve a problem.
So naturally, I'll
go to the APIs first.
OK, if I can solve a problem
using the APIs, that's perfect.
I can finish there.
But then if the APIs don't
quite do exactly what I want,
I build a custom
model with AutoML.
And then if AutoML's patterns
don't match what I'm doing,
I do a custom model with
custom training routines
and things like that.
So yeah, pretty much the
exact same thing you said.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, it's
great that maybe you're
a developer who just
wants to solve a problem.
How do I get from A to B?
So that's where those
APIs might come in.
But also, if you go
all the way down,
that's the path the developers
I work with normally go through.
But if you are building
your own custom model,
you have a lot of different
options right in Vertex, right?
TensorFlow, PyTorch.
You know, you can really
kind of do anything
that you need to in
one of the notebooks.
So yeah, there's a lot in there.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Great, great.
So we have some folks
that are looking
at Vertex for the first time.
And then we have some folks
that may have some existing
models, some that are
new to Google Cloud, some
who have used it for a while.
So our next question is about
getting started with Vertex AI.
So let's start with Anu.
Just what are your
thoughts on how to get
started from wherever your
starting point might be?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, so
one of our colleagues,
Sara-- she's published a number
of Codelabs that will not only
illustrate what you can do.
It will give you
step-by-step instructions,
whether you want to train
a model using TensorFlow.
We actually have some tech demos
on the demos website at I/O
that will show you high
level what you can do.
But then these Codelabs give
you step-by-step instructions
on setting up for
yourself, also GCP credit
if you might not
already be a GCP user
to test all these things out.
So I definitely
suggest starting there.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Fantastic.
And, Zack, one of my
favorite tutorials
is the one that you've
built with Dale on our team
around analyzing
your tennis serve.
You know, it's a lab that I've
run through several times.
What are your thoughts
on just how to get
started, get practicing
using AI on Google Cloud?
What are your thoughts?
ZACK AKIL: Getting
started, I always-- like,
of my favorite APIs is the
Video Intelligence API,
and that's the same API
we used in that demo
to do pose recognition.
And the great thing about
that is if you're just getting
started, and if you look
into it-- and of course,
it can be quite intimidating.
But then if you look
into using these APIs,
it's a pretrained model.
So especially things like
the Video Intelligence API--
it's my favorite
one because it has
so many rich features in there.
And what's really cool
about these features is
you just feed it a video,
and it will tell you
some really incredible
things like if there's
any people in it, if they're
posing in a specific way,
or if there's text in the video.
So if you're just
getting started,
it's a really quick win to be
had with any data you have,
because naturally, people
have videos lying about.
In fact, Dale also did
a really cool project
where she analyzed archival
footage that her dad recorded.
So it goes to show
people just have
videos and unstructured
data, which
is what we call videos and
text and stuff-- they just
have that lying around.
So just using one of
these APIs with the data
you already have is
a really cool way
to just almost get
motivated when you're
getting into machine learning.
So that's my recommendation is,
get a quick win using an API.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Yeah,
it makes a lot of sense.
And Zack, some of the stories
that we've built as a team
are just really
good ways, as you
mentioned, looking at
some of the family photos
and categorizing them.
Another thing that folks have
been really excited about
is we did a series
around taking a PDF file
and turning it
into an audio book
and by trying to
solve that problem,
getting familiar with using
some of our speech APIs
and things like that.
So yeah, I think it's all about
just like anything in tech,
just finding
something that you're
interested in where maybe
AI can apply, and just
go ahead and go for it.
If you're new to Vertex,
there are several sessions,
of course, during I/O. Sara
Robinson is giving one that's
an intro that I think will
do a nice overview of getting
to know the different
services, how it works.
If you go to the
documentation, there
are several hello-world-style
tutorials for Vision or NLP
or all the different
types of AI that you're
going to find there.
So that will get you started.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, my
favorite one that Sara did--
I think she just did the
workshop that must have
just ended, but it's recorded.
It's using tabular data and
Vertex to make a prediction.
So that's another
good I/O resource
you should look out for.
KARL WEINMEISTER:
Yeah, for sure.
OK, so our next question,
let's talk about MLOps.
OK, so the question
is, "It seems
that Vertex AI has a lot
of 'MLOps' capabilities.
Why is MLOps important
to developers?"
And I can start with this one.
So in the development
world, we've
had some practices
for a long time,
right-- continuous integration,
continuous development.
We have ways of
unit tests that we
can check that what we're
doing is going to work,
that as we make changes to our
code, it's not going to break.
Now machine learning is making
mission-critical decisions
about things.
It's classifying things,
predicting things.
We need that same level
of rigor around the models
that we build to prevent
a disaster from happening,
a bad model going
into production.
So MLOps is all about it.
So Vertex AI has some really
interesting capabilities
built in.
So one is called
Manage Pipelines.
And Manage Pipelines
allows you to create
a reproducible pipeline,
a set of steps,
where you can basically
hit the Play button.
And it will, if you
code it this way,
extract data from your data
sources, build a model,
deploy your model,
maybe validate the data
that you're using to
make sure that some
of the data that you're
pulling from-- there
weren't changes into
the schema or anything.
And then maybe you
evaluate your model
and make sure that the
accuracy hasn't gone down
before you deploy it.
Those are all the kind of things
that you can do in a pipeline.
Another really cool thing
is called Model Monitoring.
And I know Zack wrote
an article about this
a while back about zombie
data in your models.
It was very cool,
good introduction
that you could find on Medium.
And it's this idea
that you build models
based on data in the past.
But we all know
things change, right?
And so that model that
had really good accuracy
could start to drift over time.
And that's where Model
Monitoring comes in.
It's not like typical
software development
where it just breaks--
it's works, or it doesn't.
ML, there's a little more
nuance, where it could work,
but it just starts
to degrade over time.
And Model Monitoring
[? allow you ?] to catch that.
So these are just a couple of
examples of the integrated ways
that you can apply
DevOps principles to ML
that are all part of Vertex AI.
So definitely recommend
checking that out.
OK, so our next question
is about leveraging
pretrained models from Google.
So with that one, why
don't we start with Zack?
ZACK AKIL: Yeah, so this is
my bread and butter here.
So I love just building
things really quickly.
So the great thing
with pretrained APIs--
you don't need to do the most
intense part of the machine
learning process, which is
actually building the model,
getting the data set, making
sure it's clean and stuff,
and then train your model,
and then the deployment of it.
You don't need to
do any of that.
You can just call an API
and send your data to it,
and you get a
response from the API.
So yeah, like I said
previously, favorite one's Video
Intelligence.
And there's ones for image
prediction and text prediction.
And yeah, they're just really
fun to play with, especially
if you're involved
in any hackathons,
it goes to show how
quickly you can use them.
And they even have built-in
demos for the Vision API right
into the docs page,
where you can just--
what I'll usually do
if someone's curious
about building an image-based
app for machine learning
is I'll say, go to the
docs, drag the image
that you're planning to use or
an example image into the demo
there, and see what it returns.
And just see, is
any of this useful?
And if it is, then you'd
probably just use the API.
And it tells you
right there the web
request to send to call the API.
So it's very much, like, try it.
It's free to try,
and it's instant.
So you'll find out immediately
if it can be useful.
And if it is, it's quick as
well to just implement and use.
So it's one of these things--
like I said previously, it's
just a really quick win if
it can solve your problem.
So it's worth trying out.
So I'd say look into the docs.
There's usually
quick-to-activate demos.
And yeah, just try them out.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, I
love those demos that we
have in all the landing pages.
So not only Video Intelligence
and Vision, but also NLP--
maybe you're working
with some text data,
and you want to
gather sentiment.
You can put some samples
in there and get that back.
You know, as far as on
the pretrained side,
we've had some of the basic
APIs around for a while.
And let's say that you're
in an industry like health
care or financial services.
You know, we're
building on top of these
to have even more specialized
APIs that you can use.
So you might be familiar
with natural language.
Well, there's
actually now a health
care natural language
API that you can also
test out in the same way.
So I'm just really excited to
see all these things growing
and being even more targeted
and useful to our developers.
KARL WEINMEISTER:
Yeah, if there's
a tool to solve your
problem quickly, go for it.
These APIs allow you
to just integrate.
You know, call the REST API.
Use the SDK.
You don't have to train
a model and all that.
Very quick, so a great
place to get started.
One other thing just to mention
as far as pretrained models is,
some of the models
that you may have heard
of coming out of
Google Research are
available on TensorFlow Hub.
So you can leverage models
that you may have heard of--
BERT for natural language
processing and some
of the other image models.
You can use those and even
do things like fine tune
those models, where there
are large models that
are trained on a
general data set,
but you can leverage the
concepts that they've learned
and kind of just adjust
them for your data set.
So TensorFlow Hub is a great way
to pull those down and leverage
those models if you want
to do some custom work.
So let's move on to
our next question.
And I think that's a good follow
up to what we're talking about,
Zack, in the video API.
So "what's your favorite ML API
that's underutilized by devs?"
ZACK AKIL: Well, I know
what my favorite is--
Video Intelligence.
I think it's probably
not underutilized
because I think people-- there's
quite a lot of developers
I've already seen who are using
it for doing things like label
detection, where
it just gives you
searchable terms for your video.
And object detection-- those are
two, the most mature features
of the API.
But what people
might not be aware of
is that there's
actually loads and loads
of new features, things
around detecting people
and their poses that's
not part of the API.
Things like OCR is built
in and brand detection.
So maybe you're building an app.
You want to detect if someone's
doing product placement in it.
That's just built into the API.
You don't need to train
your own model to do it.
Again, it's one of these things,
like with all the other APIs,
they have a range of features.
And they're constantly
adding new features to them.
So it's just worth, like, if
you're working with video,
look at the Video
Intelligence API,
because there will probably
be some useful features.
And the same goes for
image and natural language.
But I think certain features
of the Video Intelligence API
are definitely right
hot off the press.
So naturally, there's not going
to be a lot of developers aware
of them.
But yeah, there's some
really cool features
around person detection.
So yeah, Video Intelligence
person detection.
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
Ooh, you know what?
We haven't talked
about chat bots yet,
and that's also a big
part of our platform.
Also, I'm not sure if
it's underutilized,
but let's talk about it now--
Dialogflow and
Contact Center I think
is really helpful if you
are building a chat bot
or doing anything
conversationally.
My background-- I actually
worked in the chat bot space
before I came to AI.
And it is really hard to build
a useful, natural-sounding chat
bot.
And so I highly
recommend, if that
is something you're
looking into,
go ahead and test out
Dialogflow because you
can use natural language
capabilities out of the box.
But you can also augment
it with your own data,
so it knows special
nouns to your use case.
So there's a lot in
there, and I think
it's a really neat
product to integrate with.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Absolutely.
Yeah, and it's really cool
how a lot of the AI products
work well with each
other's connections.
Like, you've worked
with chat bots,
where there's natural language
or speech elements to them.
Document AI has that OCR
and also text processing.
So anyway, just lots and lots of
different ways to go about it.
So our next question, I
think, is a really good one
from the audience, especially
if you're a developer,
and you're not
really sure, should I
apply AI to this or not?
So the question is, "How do
you spot a problem which can be
'AI'ified'"--
I like that-- "versus more
conventional methods?"
And I can start
off with this one,
that I think that the
real difference between AI
and traditional
software development
is that in software development,
you have a set of inputs.
And you know what
the rules are, right?
You're coding it up.
If this, then that, and then
you come up with an output.
AI is good when you
don't really know what
those rules should be, right?
You have a set of inputs, and
you have a set of outputs.
Like, I have a
bunch of pictures.
And I know I can label
what's in those pictures.
But I'm not exactly sure
how I got from point A
to point B. What were the rules?
What were the particular pixels
and colors that led to that?
Or another example
might be you're doing
some forecasting on the future.
You're looking at the
markets, and you're
trying to look at
these trends over time.
You don't know what
those rules are,
but that's where machine
learning can come in-- maybe
that there's some pattern
that can be discovered.
So essentially what
you're doing is
you're figuring out
what those rules are,
versus traditional methods,
you kind of have an approach.
You know what those
rules or heuristics are.
So sorry if that was a little
philosophical of an answer,
but that's kind of
my take on that.
Zack or Anu, any
other thoughts on when
to spot a good AI problem?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: I have I kind of
funny, I guess, rule of thumb.
You know, if you can
do it with a SQL query,
and you don't actually
have unknowns,
it might not be
the right problem.
But there could be other
problems in your space
that you need to think
about that don't actually
have common path that
AI could help you.
But definitely be careful
because there is a little bit
of unknown in the mix.
Check out explainable
AI, because if you're
doing something
that you have users,
you want to be really careful
and transparent about what
you're doing with data.
So that's my rule
of thumb, I guess.
ZACK AKIL: I think I've got a
similar thing where it's like,
rather than knowing what can
be AI, knowing for sure what
doesn't need to be AI
is as useful of a thing.
Like, I think there's as a
classic story of how Google
detects when you
should have attached
an attachment in a Gmail thing.
People are like, oh
surely, it's they
use AI for that to do natural
language classification.
Like, did they say they
would attach an attachment?
And if it comes back predicting
they should have, then
send them a message,
when actually, then, they
worked as actually
just an if statement--
if they mention the word
"attachment," "attached,"
people just use that.
It's like, if you can solve
it with an if statement,
probably don't need to use AI.
But then also a
thing that I think
will make things a bit
simpler is that there's
just so many common patterns.
Like, if you're working
with images, that's classic.
Video, classic.
Large bodies of text,
classic AI-- all this kind
of unstructured data
that doesn't necessarily
fit into columns
in a database, then
you can imagine there's
something to do with AI there.
And what I usually recommend to
people who ask me is, like, oh,
how would I solve this
specific problem with AI?
I just ask them, oh, well,
what problem that you know
is already solved with AI
that is similar to this?
So someone was like, oh,
how do I do this thing out
of some obscure time
series data, is like,
how do I solve this
problem with AI?
I'm like, well, it
kind of sounds like--
it's called trigger
word detection,
which is the same thing they use
when you're trying to activate
your phone's assistant.
We're just detecting
that one word over time.
I was like, look into that.
That'll probably tell you
the right steps to take.
So yeah, I'd recommend
just exposing yourself--
and a good thing is
coming to this AMA--
is just exposing
yourself to as many
different random solutions.
And then you'll draw links
to, like, oh, they solved
something similar with AI.
Maybe I can solve it
with this one as well.
So yeah, just get out there
and see all the different demos
and examples.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Good answer.
So the next one, I
think, is a good question
because it's funny how
we're getting questions
on the questions we've
already answered.
So we have basically a
few similar questions
I'm just going to
group into one here.
There was a question
about where to get
the step-by-step tutorials
mentioned by Anu,
as well as the tabular data
tutorial and Zack's tutorial.
So I want to mention
one resource--
Codelabs.
Codelabs.developers.google.com.
You know, you can
google that and find it.
We have already several
Vertex AI Codelabs available
and a whole bunch of
other awesome resources
to learn Cloud AI,
TensorFlow, things like that.
And so yeah, so I was
just going to check,
Anu or Zack, any other thoughts
on where to get tutorials,
getting started, resources?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah,
in addition to Codelabs
that have the
step-by-step instructions,
I'm also really a huge
fan of the Quickstarts
and the code
snippets that we have
embedded in our documentation.
For several of the
API methods, we'll
actually sketch
it out for you in
several different languages--
so Java, Node, Python.
So you can kind
of copy and paste
into maybe a code sample
for the framework or service
that you're already
using, or maybe something
that you're more familiar with.
And these are all actually-- we
really believe in open source.
So all of our code snippets
are on GitHub in repos.
So if there's something that
you want to contribute or file
a bug on or ask for
help, that's how you
can get help with those things.
ZACK AKIL: I totally
plus 1 on that.
Like, the the code
snippets in the docs
are a really good source.
Also, if you look towards the
official Google Cloud blog,
we usually post around really
nice vertical solutions in it
that involve the AI/ML APIs
and tools-- oh, and usually
within an actual story
of how it's actually
used to solve a real problem.
So that's also a good example
of seeing how they're used.
And there will also be code
snippets and samples and links
to GitHub repos in there.
KARL WEINMEISTER: Perfect.
All right, so our next
question is around
doing AI in the cloud.
I really like this question
because it kind of brings it
all together.
So the question
is, "Why would I do
AI in the cloud over
somewhere else?"
So who wants to
take that question?
ZACK AKIL: Ooh, so I like this
question, because, yeah, I
started off by
learning programming
using things like Arduino.
It's very low-level
hardware devices.
So I've always
been like, I always
like building things locally
on my own computer and machine.
And then when I started
learning about machine
learning and doing it
all on my own machine,
the first thing that I
encountered was my poor laptop
couldn't handle the amount
of data and training.
And I'd run out of
hard drive space.
So the biggest reason I'd
say is the scalability
of just the data set itself.
And considering that
the more data you have,
the better your model,
it's a classic example.
Having a place where you
can safely upload huge data
sets to train
models and not have
to worry about your local
computer making your own room
very, very warm is a
huge benefit for me.
So yeah, my main thing is
just having a safe place
where I can put huge data
sets and do all the training
in the cloud so that I can use
my local machine to do things
which it needs to do,
like playing games.
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
[LAUGHS] For sure.
I mean, I feel like it's almost
why cloud in general, right?
Like, I just want to write code.
I'm a developer.
I don't want to have to do
the ops, the system admin
sort of work.
And the point of cloud
is to sort of offload
that so you can really
focus on the problem
that you're actually
trying to solve.
KARL WEINMEISTER:
Absolutely, yeah.
And my experience is kind of
similar to Zack's, as when
I first got into data science,
one of the things I would do
is go to Kaggle.
And it's a data
science community.
I was doing competitions,
and one of them
was Titanic that maybe
some of you have tried.
And I just remember
spending hours
waiting for my model to train.
And then I'd make one little
change and have to wait.
My little desktop computer was
just buzzing for hours, right?
And these are the kind of
things if it's taking too long,
you can crank it up and have
a higher level chip with more
GPUs or more RAM.
You can really just solve
these problems so much quicker.
And then when you're done
using it, you're done using it.
And you can turn
off your notebook.
But anyway, just
fast, easy to use.
I love it.
Couldn't go back.
ZACK AKIL: [INAUDIBLE].
And on that, the big
one, another huge one
for me is when I first
started working at Google,
I started building demos.
Then I started
building big demos
that involved multiple people.
And so the amount
of collaboration
that you can achieve when things
are all in the cloud-- like,
let me just add you
to that project.
Well, now you have access
to the notebook and stuff.
That, I could never do using
a local machine because having
done data science projects
with just local machines,
like using GitHub, and people
have different environments
set up--
I mean, it saves so much
hassle, just being like,
here's the notebook.
It's got everything installed.
It's already running.
You don't need to install
anything on your laptop.
You can even access it on
your phone if you want--
like that.
The environment itself having
those libraries installed,
I'd say is one of the
biggest reasons for me.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Oh, yeah.
So actually, I didn't start
coding until I was in college.
And when I first
started, I didn't
know about all these tools.
So I remember doing
group projects.
We would actually be emailing
the code files back and forth
to each other.
So thankfully, tooling is out
there and readily accessible.
KARL WEINMEISTER: OK.
Well, fantastic conversation.
I think we're out
of time, everyone.
Great question
from the audience.
Anu, Zack, awesome
being with you again.
Thanks so much, everyone.
We'll wrap up our session today.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]